ouais différence entre sébastien loeb et
nicolas sarkozy je sais pas sébastien
loeb il a été le premier à monte carlo
et sarkozy il a été le dernier à monter
car la ola du coup c'est on est chez un
médecin la scène se passe chez le
médecin et le médecin il est avec son
patient il dit écoutez monsieur rami
j'ai eu vos résultats d'examens il va
falloir que vous arrêtiez de masturber
pourquoi parce que je suis en train de
vous parler monsieur ravi quoi le congo
qui reconnaît pas et il arrive au bas et
10e jour un coca s'il vous plaît donc la
veille regarde le kangoo assez épaté par
ce qui se passe à prendre un coca île où
il tend comme ça au kangoo kangoo prend
avec cette voie ça le coquet ille sais
quoi je vous dois mais qui va 8 euros
angot il fait comme ça may cry dédié
suis excusé moi je suis pas très
habitués à voir un kangourou dans mon
bail à 8 euros le coquin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et de psychologie pas dit il un point il
est dans l'amphithéâtre elle apprend aux
étudiants les différents stades de la
colère pour ça ce livre est l'expérience
il prend son téléphone et compose un
numéro et césar évidemment le son du
téléphone est amplifiée dans l'ampli
tout le monde sera réhaussé décroche
c'est une dame alors dix mots jean adam
ce que je pourrais parler chaque s'il
vous plaît et la dame dit je suis
désolée monsieur vous avez dû vous
trompez sûrement de téléphone mais il
n'y a pas de jacky si tu raccroches ya
ça c'est le premier stade de
l'énervement qui couve deuxième savent
recompose le numéro s'assomme la même
dame décroche
ils y vont changer lorsque je préparais
un jax immeuble elle dit non vous venez
[Applaudissements]
ça monte vite
deuxième stade avancé ah oui on va voir
le troisième stade recompose numéro
bonjour encore ce que je ferai parler
chaque s'il vous plaît pétards
dans un rôle qui manque c'est jusqu'à
l'extinction de voix
j'y voyais c'était le stade ultime pas
ultime
il ya un stade encore aux deux que je
vais vous faire écouter appelle le mtt
el amal décroche et dieu sait choc
est-ce que j'ai eu des messages
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]